foreign
Jade we are both pretty frugal people I
would like to say this is true George
and a lot of people are struggling right
now with inflation in the economy and
there's too much month at the end of
their money so I thought it would be fun
if we gave our listeners our viewers
some inflation hacks per se I love it
when I say hacks they all take work and
so there's no true like life hack this
is here's some sacrifices you can make
to find some margin and create some
margin in your budget every single month
so that you can accomplish your money
goals most of them are pretty simple
changes though if we really look at this
list George let's let's get into it yeah
so let's start with groceries because
that seems to be on everyone's mind
right now none of these will blow your
mind but knowing when to buy in bulk so
you can ask yourself a few questions can
I eat it before it goes bad because if
you buy in bulk and it all goes bad you
wasted a whole bunch of money is the
price per ounce cheaper most people are
not doing the math a lot of times it's
actually on the label it will show you
the per ounce price and so just because
you got at the Wholesale Club doesn't
always mean it's cheaper than at their
local groceries that's true I made that
mistake with jelly and here's a big
question asked do I have room to store
all of this muclix so much music oh
don't do it so storage can be it can be
a problem if you don't have a lot of
space and then obviously will I actually
use this so there's some of course
choosing generic brands that's a tough
one for a lot of people who are married
to their brand name they're made in the
same Factory people it's just marketing
it's literally just a different label on
it let your tell your brain that next
time you go to the store because it's
true yeah the acetam minifin versus the
Tylenol is the same thing made on the
same line yep and you know I love this
one George eat less meat that's a big
one for you that's coming from me y'all
know I'm the resident you're a
vegetarian me eating Americans when you
say stuff it's not a look I'm not
telling them to go hungry I'm telling
them to eat a different form of protein
and a lot of times you're getting the
same amount of protein per ounce I just
feel like to it tofu infringes on my
rights as an American George you come to
the house tonight I will prepare you the
best tofu you've ever had in your life
and you will Rave and you will go on the
streets and rip your shirt off until
these people how great that's not that
America needs right now
unbelievable uh another thing you can do
switch up the grocery store a lot of you
you're stuck I go to this grocery store
what I'm telling you Christina Ellis is
doing her no spend challenge she's been
shopping at Aldi and I am just shocked
at how how much she can stretch those
dogs she's spending under a hundred
dollars a week for a family of four
family four don't don't tell me it can't
be done it can be done shopping online
can be helpful if you're one of those
compulsive going by the snack aisle type
shop so ordering in the app for pickup
and maybe having an accountability
partner to yes look over what you are
ordering be careful though because
sometimes in those apps they do add
premiums I know the Publix apps they the
Publix app trips just I'm letting you
know I would much rather do that with
like some of the other apps that don't
add as much of a premium that's good and
of course meal plan Jade you're amazing
at this I know it's work people are like
meal plan it's like CrossFit I'm not
there's too much work it's work on the
front end what you need to do is get a
list of me like start start out by
writing out all the meals you love all
your family favorites then you can come
on websites or or you know social medias
like mine and get you know some other
ideas and then after that it's just
about plug and play the hardest part is
writing out and really getting that kind
of list of all the things that you like
to eat separating it out but we've got
you covered well now you can just Google
and YouTube all this stuff you cannot
invent it from scratch no you don't but
you know people eat the same thing over
and over they get bored and uh we don't
need to talk about eating out because
the best hack for inflation is just to
not eat out if you don't have to and if
you if you are like I don't have enough
money at the end of the month one of the
easiest ways to make money back into
your life is by not eating out it is
astronomically expensive these days and
okay that's a good point George but even
for folks let's say you're in baby step
three and you're doing you know you're
past that baby step two phase but you're
still like man this inflation and you're
going to restaurants every now and then
can you can you pick it up instead of
dining in yes you can avoid the tip and
here's my favorite tip for folks who are
still going to restaurants but trying to
save leave your kids at home that's big
don't bring those but then you gotta
hire a babysitter you gotta offset the
cost now George I would rather pay for
child care than to pay 14 for whatever
their food was and it ends up on the
floor oh and I'm talking about times two
because I got two kids warshaw kids
she's coming for you all right let's
move on to housing utility saving on
your electric bill there's a lot of
things you can do here number one
replace those air filters they're
probably crispy and nasty and it's time
anyways that's right your air filter
your your HVAC is having to work so hard
it's working overtime because of those
nasty filters only run appliances when
they're full that means being a little
more strategic a little more patient
turn off the dang lights when you're not
using them and if my dad is listening
he's like yes I want to know how much
does it really saved because I grew up
on that today's job it adds up cut that
light off uh and washing your clothes in
cold water I was just watching so
someone needs an appliance Pro and they
were like washing cold water with
today's detergents it's going to clean
it just as well as your hot water yes it
does that's a great one save money there
um water bills take quicker showers
notice I didn't say fewer I said quicker
some of y'all y'all need to you're
cleaning out like it's a hot tub in
there get get what you need to get done
and get out why are you coming at me
this hour why are you coming at me well
this is I think this is a woman problem
now some guys probably take super long
showers man it's a long the long hot
shower until the skin comes off oh I'm
just burning myself in there uh don't
run the dishwasher or laundry until the
machine is full that's another good one
turn off the tap when you brush your
teeth I'm guilty of that one when you're
shaving washing your hair turn off the
tap don't just let it run for fun it is
very good we live in a society people
act like it and then you can install a
low flow shower head so now people get
upset about this one this is taking it
too far well some of those shower heads
I mean this just the the pressure coming
out of those things we'll take your skin
off so yeah I'm just saying that all
that helps rent this is a tough one
right people are going well my rent's so
expensive if you're single it may be
time to get a roommate and cut it out
yeah if you're married some married
couples are like we got an extra room
we're going to use this to make money we
did it when we were in baby step two our
rent was 1200 a month and we as married
people got roommates who were other
married people and we did it for a year
and saved 600 bucks a month that's a
life hack right there and then you can
also look into a lease that's longer
than a year if you know you're going to
be somewhere for a while you can sign up
for a longer lease which can lower your
rent which is great and here's a life
hack move out and find somewhere cheaper
to live it exists and you might not want
to do it but that's one way to lower
your cost there transportation is
another one that has gotten real
expensive and so things like combining
your errands there are gas reward
programs out there that are free that
can save you a few cents on the dollar
um You probably have all this all the
crap in your car that may be weighing
down your car that's true and that can
help with your fuel economy and cruise
control aggressively speeding and
breaking on the highway all that that
can lower your gas mileage by from 50
cents to two dollars a gallon two
dollars that's true just I I remember my
dad used to tell me take the highway
because it's less stop and go and you'll
save on gas dads way to go Dad way to go
there they were the first Frugal folks
out there I love it he was the one that
said cut the light off and now let's end
with some lifestyle savings hacks and
the biggest one is subscriptions
we live in the subscription economy and
they all add up and everyone wants to
nickel and dime you for their thing
Prime has gotten I love me some prime
but they've gotten out of control with
this price so if you let's just say you
cut you know Netflix is now 16 bucks a
month spotify's 10 bucks a month YouTube
programs 12 bucks a month Hulu without
the ads of 13 bucks a month that's 50
bucks a month just on TV shows and music
and I can't keep up with the amount of
content on there now if you have enough
can can I just say this I'm about to to
harp on so and I'm talking to myself too
if you have all these subscriptions and
you're using all you're watching that
much TV we need to find something else
to do with our time and I'm saying we an
hour because I'm in it too well what's
amazing is you cut all the subscriptions
because you got a part-time job now
because you're trying to get out of debt
yeah you don't miss it you're too busy
you're too busy working and that's 600
bucks a year that you can throw at debt
you can afford your groceries all that
kind of stuff and extra time you'll have
when you're not you're watching I don't
know what the cool shows are Emily in
Paris I don't know what's cool these
days it sounds like you watch Emily in
Paris George
don't buy clothing unless it's an actual
need that's very so many clothes in
America today your closet is just full
of crap that you once thought was going
to be cute yeah and now it's still got
tags on and there's really cool ways
that you can do those clothing exchanges
too like if you have something and you
paid a little bit of money for it you
can go on one of those exchanges sell it
and then maybe take the money and either
put it towards debt or buy something
else so it's more of an exchange yes and
lastly make coffee at home I know it's
one of those tried and true wow what's
the five bucks oh it it's up and it
tastes better George because it you get
it right every time that's right and you
can make your own little frothy lattes
at home it's fourteen dollars cheaper
than Starbucks and no more gas station
runs that is keeping y'all broke every
day get my little snack in my little
drink that's how they're making their
money and it's putting the pounds on too
don't don't sleep on it good hacks
thanks Jade